Now let's look at the different
types of viruses.
The first is a parasitic virus.
They typically scan
programs on a system, for
example on the hard drive, and
then infect these programs.
The second is the memory-resident virus.
They're typically of an operating
system, and when the system runs,
the opening system is
loaded into the memory.
So as long as a system is running,
the virus, resize the memory.
Then it can infect any running
program on the system.
The third is the macro virus.
They're typically
embedded in a document.
And when a document is opened,
the virus also runs and spreads.
The fourth, is the Boot sector virus.
They reside in the boot
sector of a hard drive, and
whenever a system is booted the Boot
sector virus will run and spread.
A very important type of virus
is called a Polymorphic virus.
For a Polymorphic virus,
each instance, or each infection,
can look different because part of the
virus program is encrypted by a randomly
generated key at each infection.
The purpose of using polymorphic
virus is to avoid detection by
easy signature matching.
We will discuss this a little bit later.
We should note that any of these
type of viruses can by polymorphic.